let's start with this news we've had
coming in in the last sort of half hour
of Russia announcing that it will be
paying its soldiers more yes uh 10 more
from October is what we hear it makes
perfect sense I mean the Army's loyalty
is not guaranteed to put in since last
weekend but they've got a real problem
with pay because they've been offering
new recruits a lot of money I mean up to
nine thousand dollars and the average
salary in Russia is less than a thousand
dollars a month so yeah monthly salaries
nine times the average and that's
causing big problems because some of
these new recruits are turning up being
paid a great deal more than the officers
and so that that's become a difficult
problem they've got to do something
about that and army morale is suffering
because of that and also they've got a
big labor shortage in Russia I mean
almost two percent labor shortage
um and that's just this year and that's
just people going to the Army or fleeing
abroad so it's a big problem they've got
to do something about it and this is to
encourage the troops to to say that we
are we are evening out the pay
differentials which have become a real
problem for them this year okay and
meanwhile the Wagner group there's been
some sightings of movement obviously in
Belarus where the leader of the Wagner
group is supposed to have gone but let's
talk let's talk first about the group
and then where he progressionally yeah
this this space is being opened as a
place called azerbiji which is about 50
miles south of Minsk around about there
and it's an old base uh it's got some uh
um uh artillery brigades there but
azerbiji um is a base that this is a an
image from planet labs and this was the
image from the 15th of June a couple of
weeks ago the image today shows what has
changed there's all the uh there's all
the stuff on the base these are the sort
of the the local accommodation the tense
military tents that have been put up and
this is worth about 8 000 people and
that's about right that's what we
thought the Wagner group actually had in
reality in this mad march to Moscow a
week ago so yes if they're going to go
there that's fine if they go there but
pragosian we don't know where he is the
leader of wardner maybe he's there maybe
he's back in Petersburg he seems to have
been spotted in Petersburg and read all
depend is what he intends he's obviously
negotiating there's a lot going on so
this Wagner issue between pragos in
lukashenker of Belarus and Putin itself
these politics still carry on it will be
quite a an interesting week for Watchers
like me certainly we know that you will
be uh watching it and bringing uh what
do you find out to us at Michael Clarke
thank you very much